nadie nunca dice yo simplemente no leo o
no me gusta el español pero está
perfectamente bien y es socialmente
aceptable decir no sé matemáticas
vivimos en un mundo muy cuantitativo y
yo quiero ayudar a los alumnos a ver
cómo las matemáticas están en todas
partes cuando lanzan una pelota cuando
beben un vaso de agua y quiero que sean
capaces de pensar cuantitativamente
porque para mí es una habilidad inmensa
que les ayudará de muchas formas a salir
adelante en la vida
son mi san josé es la tercera escuela de
la red de escuelas públicas hamid hace
pocos años se habló de la primera
escuela se omite en el documental en
espera de superman y nosotros empezamos
a este año como la tercera escuela de la
red
cuando abrimos esta escuela decidimos
que haríamos algo diferente a las otras
escuelas o mets así que tenemos un
programa especial de matemáticas
combinamos la instrucción cara a cara
con el aprendizaje por computadora de
maneras muy significativas para los
chicos para generar las mejores
experiencias de aprendizaje fue el año
escolar pasado que escuchamos en cada
academia cuando se emitió la primera
charla de tests examinamos los
contenidos y nos prometieron tener con
nosotros una relación sólida y ayudarnos
cuando lo necesitamos
empezamos el año sin saber en absoluto
que iba a pasar habíamos trabajado bien
con ellos les habíamos dicho lo que
necesitábamos y ellos nos lo han
proporcionado y a otros maestros y creo
que esto va a mejorar cada vez más
khan academy es magnífico por muchas
razones hace más algo tu trabajo porque
fija más alto tu objetivo de lo que
debieras planificar para tus alumnos una
vez que obtienes toda esa información a
la que es muy fácil acceder dices tal
vez la elección que pensaba que estaba
bien para toda la clase esté bien solo
para el 20% de ella debería replantearme
en lo que les estoy pidiendo a mis
alumnos ya sea algo muy elevado para el
80% de la clase o algo de muy bajo nivel
para el grupo en general cuando dejas
una tarea a menudo estás consolidando
las malas prácticas y los conceptos
erróneos lo que can hace muy bien es dar
retroalimentación instantánea a los 36
chicos de mi clase de una forma en la
que yo nunca podría hacerlo así que cada
alumno obtiene retroalimentación
instantánea con cada problema y esos
conceptos erróneos no se consolidan creo
que algo que khan está transformando
radicalmente
ahora en verdad están aprendiendo
procesos de manera correcta no solamente
pasar por pasar los estudiantes lo ven
como un juego de vídeo en ellos te
equivocas todo el tiempo verdad pues en
matemáticas te equivocas todo el tiempo
en todo lo de la escuela debes de
equivocarte todo el tiempo y aprender de
esos errores y lo que hemos notado que
es estupendo es que los alumnos aprenden
de sus errores antes de que sea
demasiado tarde y que aprenden las
matemáticas en lugar de seguir fingiendo
que las entienden de la misma manera que
lo hace un adulto
los estudiantes se fijan metas muy
específicas y factibles y continúan
motivados ahora todos pueden acercarse a
khan academy decir mi meta es terminar
estos seis ejercicios y entonces en la
parte superior realizas un seguimiento
que te muestra que el porcentaje
terminaste y cuando alcanzaste una meta
esta forma de validación sí que les
gusta a nuestros alumnos fijarse una
meta alcanzarla y así obtener una
sensación de logro
transformó a mis alumnos porque ahora
son más responsables y saben dónde están
parados
definitivamente saben si saben algo o no
son mucho más expresivos y abogan más
por sí mismos y me transformó a mí
porque ahora sé mucho más de ellos cerca
de mí no les permite a los estudiantes
esconder los rezagos en sus
conocimientos en verdad te desafía a dar
lecciones excelentes a tantos
estudiantes como sea posible porque
tienes toda esa información acerca de
ellos es formidable para motivarlos y
para que practiquen no volvería a
enseñar como antes si tengo esta opción